THE COMMONWEALTH.
WE'RE JUST FOUR DAYS AWAY FROM
THE HIGHLY ANTICIPATED PRIMARY
ELECTIONS.
FOR REPUBLICANS, A LAST-MINUTE
WILD CARD IN THE SENATE RACE IS
CAUSING MAJOR CONCERN.
MOST OF THE FOLKS HAS BEEN ON
MEHMET OZ AND DAVID McCORMICK,
BUT CONSERVATIVE POLITICAL
COMMENTATOR AND FORMER RADIO
SHOW HOST KATHY BARNETTE HAS
SURGED IN RECENT POLLS LEADING
TRUMP ALLIES TO SOUND THE ALARM.
THEY SAY BARNETTE IS NOT A WELL
VETTED CANDIDATE.
WE HAVE KNOWN FOR MONTHS SHE IS
ONE OF THE MOST VOCIFEROUS
SHARERS OF LIES ABOUT THE 2020
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
NOW CNN'S K-FILE HAS UNCOVERED A
HISTORY OF STRAIGHT UP BIGISTRY.
ANTI-MUSLIM AND ANTI-GAY
STATEMENTS MADE BY BARNETTE
AFTER THE SUPREME COURT RULING
CLEARED THE WAY FOR SAME-SEX
MARRIAGE IN JULY 2015.
>> TWO MEN SLEEPING TOGETHER.
TWO MEN HOLDING HANDS.
TWO MEN CARESSING.
THAT IS NOT NORMAL.
IF LOVE IS THE LITMUS TEST, WHO
ARE WE TO SAY, WELL, YOUR LOVE
IS LEGITIMATE LOVE, SAME-SEX
COUPLES, BUT YOUR LOVE, FATHER
AND DAUGHTER, IS NOT LEGITIMATE?
OR YOUR LOVE, ONE MAN AND THREE
WOMEN, IS NOT LEGITIMATE, OR ONE
OLDER MAN AND A 12-YEAR-OLD
CHILD.
IF LOVE IS A LITMUS TEST, IT
BECOMES A VERY SLIPPERY SLOPE,
AND THAT IS WHERE WE FIND
OURSELVES TODAY.
>> ALSO IN 2015, SHE ATTACKED
TRANSGENDER OLYMPIC CHAMPION
CAITLYN JENNER AS DEFORMED AND
DEMONIC.
SHE ALSO SHARED THE INSANE
CONSPIRACY THEORY THAT FORMER
PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA WAS A
PRACTICING MUSLIM.
HE'S A MUSLIM, MUSLIM OBAMA, AND
DON'T WE GET IT, OBAMA IS A
MUSLIM, AND IN A SPEECH IN 2015,
THEE ARGUED IT WAS OKAY TO
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST MUSLIMS AND
REJECTING MUSLIMS AS REJECTING
HITLER'S OR STALIN'S WORLD
VIEWS.
>> YOU'RE NOT A RACIST IF YOU
REJECT ISLAM OR MUSLIMS BECAUSE
THEY ARE NOT A RACE OF PEOPLE.
THEY ARE A PARTICULAR VIEW.
THEY ARE A PEOPLE THAT HAVE A
PARTICULAR VIEW OF THE WORLD.
AND WE HAVE A RIGHT TO
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST WORLD
VIEWS.
WE DISCRIMINATED AGAINST
HITLER'S NAZI GERMANY VIEW OF
THE WORLD, RIGHT?
THAT WAS A WORLD VIEW.
THAT'S HOW HE SAW THE WORLD
AROUND HIM.
AND WE DISCRIMINATED AGAINST IT,
WE REJECTED IT.
WE REJECTED STALIN'S VIEW,
COMMUNIST VIEW OF THE WORLD,
RIGHT?
BECAUSE THAT'S A PARTICULAR VIEW
OF THE WORLD THAT WE DON'T AGREE
WITH.
>> JUST STRAIGHT UP IGNORANT
RELIGIOUS BIGOTRYBIGOTRY.
WHOEVER WINS ON TUESDAY IS
LIKELY TO FACE OFF AGAINST TWO
WELL KNOWN DEMOCRATS.
CONOR LAMB OR JOHN FETTERMAN.
KASIE HUNT TRAVELED TO YORK
COUNTY IN SOUTHERN PENNSYLVANIA
TO SEE HOW THE RACE IS SHAPING
UP WITH JUST DAYS TO GO.
>> STANDING 6'8" TALL IN GYM
SHORTS AND A HOODIE, YOU
WOULDN'T ASSUME JIM FETTERMAN IS
A POLITICIAN.
>> IS YOUR COUNTY A BLUE COUNTY?
>> GREETED LIKE A CELEBRITY AT A
LOCAL BAR HERE.
THE TATTOOED PENNSYLVANIA
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR IS THE HEAVY
FAVORITE TO WIN TUESDAY'S
DEMOCRATIC SENATE PRIMARY HERE
IN SWING STATE PENNSYLVANIA.
>> WE HAVE TO FLIP THIS SEAT.
>> THAT WILL BE TOUGH FOR ANY
DEMOCRAT.
JUST 33% OF PENNSYLVANIA VOTERS
SAY PRESIDENT BIDEN IS DOING A
GOOD JOB.
AND BECAUSE THIS RACE COULD
DECIDE CONTROL OF THE SENATE,
REPUBLICANS ARE PREPARED TO POUR
IN MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
AIRING ATTACK ADS EVEN TOUGHER
THAN THE ONES HE'S FACED FROM
HIS OWN PARTY.
>> REPUBLICANS THINK THEY CRUSH
SOCIALIST FETTERMAN.
>> HE SUPPORTED BERNIE SANDERS
FOR PRESIDENT, BACKS LEGALIZING
MARIJUANA AND USED TO CALL
HIMSELF A PROGRESSIVE.
YOU DID SAY IN 2021, I HAVE RUN
AS A PROGRESSIVE BEFORE IT WAS
COOL TO DO SO.
SO WHY WON'T YOU DO SO NOW?
>> THE PARTY HAS SHIFTED TO MY
PLATFORM.
>> CONOR LAMB CRITICIZED HIM FOR
AN INCIDENT IN 2013 WHEN HE
PULLED A GUN ON A MAN WHO TURNED
OUT TO BE AN UNARMED BLACK
JOGGER.
HE HAS REFUSED TO APOLOGIZE.
>> I THINK THAT'S DISQUALIFYING
FOR ANY OF US.
>> FETTERMAN WILL HAVE TO ANSWER
FOR THAT AND DEFEND AGAINST
REPUBLICAN ATTACKS ON ISSUES
LIKE ABORTION, IMMIGRATION, AND
CRIME.
>> HE EVEN WANTS TO REDUCE JAIL
TIME FOR MURDERERS.
JOHN FETTERMAN, TOO DANGEROUS
FOR PENNSYLVANIA.
>> YOU HAVE WORKED REALLY HARD
TO HELP FREE PEOPLE FROM PRISON.
ARE YOU CONCERNED AT ALL THAT
YOUR RECORD ON THAT IS GOING TO
COME BACK TO BITE YOU IN A
GENERAL ELECTION?
>> NO, AND IF IT IS, THEY CAN
BRING IT ON.
>> DO YOU THINK OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER IS ADEQUATELY SECURED
RIGHT NOW?
I HAVE ALWAYS BEEN AN ADVOCATE
FOR A SECURE BORDER BUT A
COMPASSIONATE AND COMMONSENSE
IMMIGRATION REFORM.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT ABORTION FOR
A SECOND.
DO YOU SUPPORT ANY RESTRICTIONS
ON ABORTION?
>> I DON'T.
I HAVE ALWAYS --
>> EVEN IN THE THIRD TRIMESTER?
>> I BELIEVE THAT CHOICE IS
BETWEEN A WOMAN, HER DOCTOR, AND
A GOD IF SHE PRAYS TO ONE.
>> REPUBLICANS ARE GUARANTEED TO
USE HIS POLICY POSITIONS AGAINST
HIM, AND THE NATIONAL MOOD GIVES
THE GOP A CLEAR ADVANTAGE
AGAINST ANY GENERIC DEMOCRAT.
BUT JOHN FETTERMAN IS ANYTHING
BUT GENERIC.
>> BASIC CORE DEMOCRATIC
PRINCIPLES.
I DON'T EVEN THINK THEY'RE
DEMOCRATIC.
THEY'RE JUST UNIVERSAL TRUTHS.
UNIVERSAL TRUTHS, YOU KNOW?
CAN YOU LIVE ON $7.25 AN HOUR?
>> IT SEEMS LIKE SOME DEMOCRATS
BEFORE YOU MAY HAVE SEATED BLUE
COLLAR VOTERS HERE IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
>> NOT THIS CAMPAIGN.
WE DON'T CHANGE OUR MESSAGE OR
WE DON'T PANDER.
BUT WE TALK ABOUT THOSE CORE
UNIVERSAL PRINCIPLES AND VALUES,
AND WE SHOW UP IN EVERY
COMMUNITY.
SOME OF THE REDDEST COUNTIES,
AND NOW IN OUR HYPERDIVIDED
POLITICAL WORLD, YOU KNOW, WHERE
IT'S ULTRA MAGA, OR REASONABLE
POLITICAL BELIEFS WHERE YOU CAN
HAVE SOME MILD DISAGREEMENTS, WE
BELIEVE WE'RE GOING TO BE COMING
DOWN ON THE RIGHT SIDE OF
HISTORY AND POLICY.
THAT'S THE KIND OF CAMPAIGN
WE'RE RUNNING.
>> SO WHETHER FETTERMAN CAN WIN
A GENERAL ELECTION WILL
OBVIOUSLY DEPEND ON WHO HE ENDS
UP RUNNING AGAINST, AS YOU
OUTLINED.
IT'S ALSO GOING TO DEPEND ON HOW
EXCITED DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO
BE TO GET OUT AND VOTE FOR HIM.
BLACK VOTERS IN PARTICULAR ARE
SUCH AN IMPORTANT PART OF THE
DEMOCRATIC BASE IN PENNSYLVANIA,
AND HE REALLY MAY HAVE SOME WORK
TO DO THERE AFTER THE ATTACKS
FROM HIS PRIMARILY RIVALS OVER
THAT 2013 INCIDENT WITH THE
UNARMED BLACK JOGGER.
JAKE.
>> ALL RIGHT, KASIE HUNT, THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
>> LET'S DISCUSS.
LET'S GO BACK TO KATHY BARNETTE,
WHO IS SURGING IN THE POLLS, AND
APPARENTLY DENYING THAT SHE SENT
SOME OF THE TWEETS THAT CLEARLY
SHE SENT AND CLEARLY FIT IN
PERFECTLY WITH THINGS SHE HAS
BEEN SAYING FOR YEARS THAT ARE
HOMOPHOBIC AND ANTI-MUSLIM AND
BIGOTED IN OTHER WAYS.
ARE YOU WORRIED AS A REPUBLICAN
WHO WANTS TO CAPTURE THAT SEAT?
ARE YOU WORIED ABOUT HER
GETTING THE NOMINATION.
>> YEAH, AND WHAT'S HAPPENING IS
STUNNING.
THERE'S SO MUCH OXYGEN AROUND
DR. OZ AND DAVE McCORMICK AND
THAT'S WHERE ALL THE FOCUS HAS
BEEN.
OUT OF LEFT FIELD, THIS VERY
EXTREMIST CANDIDATE WHO FRANKLY
MAKES OZ AND McCORMICK LOOK
ALMOST MODERATE COMPARED TO HER
POSITIONS, NOW SURGING.
THIS BRINGS BACK MEMORIES OF THE
2010 TEA PARTY WAVE WHERE
EXTREMIST CANDIDATES CHRISTINE
O'DONNELL COMES TO MIND, GOT THE
NOMINATION OF THE PARTY AND
ULTIMATELY LOST.
JAKE, YOU'RE FROM PENNSYLVANIA.
THIS IS A STATE THAT HAS
TRADITIONALLY HAD -- IT'S PURPLE
IN MANY WAYS.
WE FORGET, DONALD TRUMP DIDN'T
WIN PENNSYLVANIA, SO RUNNING ON
AN EXTREMIST FAR RIGHT PLATFORM
IS NOT A WINNING MESSAGE IF
YOU'RE TRYING TO PICK UP A
SENATE SEAT.
>> ASHLEY, TO GO TO THE
DEMOCRATIC SIDE, IT'S NOT
DIFFICULT TO ANTICIPATE HOW THAT
2013 EVENT FROM FETTERMAN'S PAST
WHERE HE STOPPED THAT BLACK
JOGGER AT GUNPOINT, HOW THAT
COULD BE USED AGAINST HIM IN THE
GENERAL ELECTION, AT THE VERY
LEAST, TO CREATE SOME LACK OF
ENTHUSIASM FOR PEOPLE TO VOTE
FOR HIM AMONG THE BLACK
COMMUNITY, OR ANYBODY ELSE
OFFENDED BY THAT ACTION.
>> YEAH, ABSOLUTELY.
I MEAN, THE INCIDENT IN 2013 IS
A TERRIBLE ONE.
THE PERSON THAT HE HELD AT
GUNPOINT SEEMS TO BE INNOCENT,
AND WE DON'T WANT THOSE TYPE OF
INCIDENTS TO HAPPEN WITH POLICE,
AND INNOCENT PEOPLE, OR WITH
CITIZENS AND ANOTHER CITIZEN.
I DO THINK HE NEEDS TO GET AHEAD
OF IT NOW IN THE PRIMARY, DEAL
WITH IT.
IT'S UNFORTUNATE HE DOESN'T WANT
TO APOLOGIZE EVEN THOUGH HE'S A
DEMOCRAT, I'M NOT GOING TO GIVE
HIM A PASS ON THAT.
RACE IS AN ISSUE IN POLITICAL
RACES FOR SURE.
WE SAW IT COME UP IN 2020, AND I
THINK IT WILL DEFINI